there and people didn't want to see a
tenshi Takeda
okay match up so they can see how they
interact so let's go ahead and do that
okay all right look at that new
background
no we're awful we'll hold off on that
all right
think your skills surpass mine I know so
dead prove it when we formed so this
variation balanced kenchi is a little
bit of a different character as far as
his common special ghost
he's got five common specials that are
themed slightly different in each
experience so look at the balance first
by the way you can see that if you're
familiar with MK 9 this tariff is back
for a lot of his specials here
so the big plus for this variation is
you a really big damage from stringing
together with large combos so it's first
especially I will look at is the rising
karma so this is a really good
close-range anti hair attack and the ex
does an extra hit on connect it's also a
great move you could actually straight
after combo to him absolutely
which raises with six or seven other
times just block guys if I got to do but
this next one is a spirit push in this
variation it's really good for close to
mid range it has a pretty big hitbox and
you cannot dunk it and it's Rex too
right yeah absolutely awesome and this
one doesn't track no this no no dad
you're you can make sure you get on
connect on this one for me the next one
up is the Teleflora this one's the track
moves it is dockable however and if you
miss it for new episode pocket it has a
pretty long delay so it is kind of semi
punishable so that's very good for
anti-air depending on our posted news
can we hold on for one second that moves
duh Keable that's right why have I not
been ducking that move I was wondering
the same thing
all right keep going beat everybody's
learning yeah he also has a TK slice now
this one you must block hi
and you hold a position on this one so
you can have three different ranges
close medium far so you can dictate we
put it then the three X has an extra hit
on connector and an X they point down
so also like some good zoning tools from
Ken at Saturday he's really good at far
and then when you give them gets up
close also and in this variant gets the
blade reflect so this reflects
projectiles and the x1 absorbs it which
will have to show live yeah they're over
jacket my dad broke your whip yeah like
that sir awesome move on we already go
to next yeah I see a thrower gonna yell
starts to a throw
alright sure look show just got it just
go crazy for a bit right do some of your
fun stuff there we go alright we go like
it like you can practice all right so
let's go on to the next one
mm-hm the next one is going to be the
possessed variations so in this one Kent
your sword sento has been broken and as
a result the the spirits that had been
trapped within the sword had been
released and kind of possessed kenchi
and so he doesn't have any attacks with
the sword in this variation at all all
of them all of his range attacks and
that sort of thing come through this
these demons that kind of come out from
him and as you can see the sorrows back
is actually cracked into pieces so it's
out there it shows the variation as well
the visual difference
you're a scoundrel says the deadbeat dad
even for you that was low Wang Yi for no
clue what they said so the something
about this trade is it's all about chunk
damage right so you know it doesn't have
his big strings as he did in the
balanced treatment say but this one it's
all about two big hits big hits so you
know a spin on the rising karma your
previous variation is the sickle lift so
again it's a close-range move it's a
multi hit on connect actual just a
little bit difference but got its roots
we add something real quickly to you
talked about how it's more chunk damage
and less combo heavy I get a lot of
tweets where people are like is Mortal
Kombat X a game that I can play as a
casual fan and yet one of the things
I've tried to start learning about
variations is there are some variations
that might be easier for a casual fan to
get used to it if they're not a combo
heavy type of person absolutely you can
learn that one and then kind of move
forward as you get back yeah absolutely
the next move is the soul push again
similar to the spirit push this is a
short to mid-range attack it's pretty
safe if you're from next range the cool
thing about this move is you gave a lot
of distance back the e X version though
if you choose to kind of come up a
mid-range that's really great for that
the next one up is the demon of Solace
it does more damage than a soul push but
it can definitely punished easily when
Walker misses okay next up is the demon
slam this one is a little bit different
than the TK studies because this one you
must block live you can also control
positioning on this one back forward and
next one of my favorite things about
this particular moves that when you exit
in combo like
I get a little lift I must've missed it
but you actually get did you actually
get an additional chance to juggle this
hey right drop something upstream I did
know I liked club so the oil reflect has
gone in this variant but he has a
alternate move in here which is pretty
awesome I love this move is the demon
beam so this move is you know teleport
and it tracks in front of the opponents
and the cool thing about it is once you
add a teleport you can you have
controllers character to form another
attack right there so it's great for
stream combos together right
also here he's got a new special in this
variant it's called the bombing strike
so this is an overhead special that's
close range and the X does a knock down
instead and it's in Harbor he also has a
new string in this one which is a
overwrite on his tak port towards so
this one reaches a little bit further
and it must block it well hey this this
can't you have does he have an x-ray I
don't know let's find out go
they're awesome
so with this variation he also gets
additional combos along with the special
attacks you get the leaders the new
strings that's right down tech forwards
cool alright so let's go onto the next
one
mmm all right let's do it kimchi looks
awesome he does if you like them in
those variations just wait to see them
in this one this one's really cool the
kenjutsu
so this one is the swordmaster Kenshin
missing his headband right so it's
pretty crazy
this variation we brought some of the TK
specials from MK da as well as we have
added some some new ones
this variation you know you can punish a
lot but the range is is a lot shorter in
general than the other two variation
gotcha
what is the secret of your powers my
secrets are my own sure we're fat so the
twist on of the short-range
anti-aircraft our DX does a multi-hit is
robbed a little bit of a twist the other
ones that variations have that stuff is
the tele push this is a pretty short to
mid-range attack it is fairly safe
except when you're up close at the
exercise the tele toss is on the next
deck subtracting its furnace move in
this variation but it is very unsafe
what's really great about your switches
sides with your opponent and the e^x
version has multiple and finally I
should say the other very imperative
from experience is a Tele slam this is a
pretty Club kind of close to mid-range
attack experience a and the really cool
thing about this move is when you
perform the e X version of this because
it brings the opponent down stunned so
you can go ahead and
I want you uh she also hasn't played
reflect oh yeah this one can you throw
that than doesn't work against the
shield we'll find out now it's too many
hits I yep so what we did today was not
show you how the blade works you're
gonna try that one out but there's more
there's more there's more yes in this
variation he has a spinning blade which
is I love this remote my favorite
specialist which is an overhead move
it's pretty cool and it's pretty point
to the e.x does an extra hit and it also
slightly juggles Nereus Amina's there
you go is it gonna be X don't dunk it
swag oh oh oh is it time for a fatality
it would be I guess let's see if we can
do it yeah this one is awesome Oh
[Music]
see you later Kotal my face and that's
pretty much it for a catchy grab your
friend look who are we gonna show next
Tyler well I'm going to take over here
for now we're going to show the love